[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dont on
n'est pas sorti de l'auberge aujourd'hui
on se retrouve dans les hauts de l'ouest
de la réunion plus précisément à la
saline-les-hauts juste à côté du musée
villèle où se trouve la table paysanne
ich habe un véritable petit bout de
réunions de vous le direz des nouvelles
allez c'est parti
[Musique]
vous l'avez janvier donc france ont su
régler la lumière coup dessus en fleurs
vous nous te bonheur des idéaux sont si
vagues la mer
de la paix la rosée schliep et à
lessines après tout la jolie manière
calbuco kirby a notamment pâti clan très
vive la
patrie oui ça va tu as dis moi c'est
magnifique quoi ça fait pas deux minutes
que je suis là je suis complètement sous
le charme mais à six vitesses et on a
l'impression de faire un bond dans le
temps c'est superbe j'ai l'habitude à
chaque fois de mettre la main à la pâte
lorsque je vais faire si je vais
t'arracher est à fourche un croc plutôt
un croc ça y est ça commence
à trouver de sacchi mais en bas on va
pas y ait un peu la pintade avec que
vous pouvez écouter et après on va le
surveiller
vous pouvez nous parler bien attaquer
alors pour toi bien
[Musique]
voilà
allez bon je lui
ai fait moi tripoli 'si je teste
allait bien et pas aux attentes et une
petite pause
bon alors des poules taqwa d'autriche et
surexploitation et simona les poules
lapins calme après de l'autre côté on a
les canards et les oies et après on fait
de la canne à sucre ça s'écoute est
vraiment que tu es agricole ici c'est
twitter coûté table et l'autre dont elle
est où tout est volé son excuse mon
portable de ce tralala
pintades en poulets canards les oies se
dessiner pas de vente avec sérieux et en
ce qui concerne la canne à sucre on a
combien de coups même superficie on a en
canne à sucre on a cinq hectares en
canne à sucre avec les différentes
variétés quand même parce que je te
propose à ces conflits ne s'occupait de
théo la normale après si tu peux m'en
vais faire un petit tour dans ton jardin
parce qu il est magnifique mais le pont
levant les bombes
[Musique]
le charme
mais l'asnl occupe des côtes
exploitation et là nous arrive dans le
jardin
est à même un petit potager ouais la
crise a un peu pour multi phy soir pour
commencer à manali un peu dans le bain
sensible italien un peu au cou dégoûtée
agricole va comme ça elle connaît pas ou
alors dans la main verte parce que
regarder web et débrouille pas mal quand
même le cycle est une addition est juste
magnifique et donc il fait pousser quoi
d'autre ici notre jardin
vers l'ailleurs il ya de la maison on a
un différend le plant et médicinales
comme et violaine et au marais et la
pana et goya marron citronnelle
géraniums et c'est utilisant la fin vous
utilisé dans la cuisine oui on utilise
au niveau culinaire pour la cuisine est
aussi un fusion après le repas voilà
même si à peine arrivé à berlin pour
leur part aussi et les fameuses banane
je tenterai pas la blague on est
favorite a pas de bouche
tu as vraiment pas mal de plans
différents c'est représentatif de la
région quoi t'as quoi en fait est que je
fais mais on en a pas mal de plantes
endémiques et les bains juin et bois de
senteur et batna le fameux bois ce faire
on a aussi et du bois de fer alors ça tu
proposes tu fais découvrir à chaque fois
tenir voilà on fait de faire un petit
tour c'est ça un jour le guide assis
voilà on fait découvrir et les andes ici
parce qu'il ya pas mal qu'ils
connaissent pas aussi
il y avait même des ruches que ses
fidèles ils ont là bientôt on va
récolter le miel de letchis aller au
moins un mois à peu près moi mes trois
semaines quand je mène à peu près tout
c'est un outil univers vraiment
sympathique où elles ont sorti amis de
la mort
paris
[Musique]
moi ça m'a ouvert l'appétit cette petite
banane
fut même la maison d'un pure tradition
créole que c'est une vieille maison non
maison assez récente quand même voilà un
acceptant à la 7 ans allez hop bien bien
bien dans le style créole que
tu me présenter ta femme du coup
et tu passe la journée avec nous quoi
non malheureusement on ne peut pas il
doit partir à ben doit prendre un cours
d'anglais sur saint pierre un commandant
lever
et on accueille des gens et j'ai tranché
patrick au mode internationale
bonjour brigitte
la bise oui
qu'est-ce que je peux faire pour t'aider
alors pour bd dont on va commencer par
la marche en avant à l'est
[Musique]
c'est parti
c'est moi je t'emmène dans le petit coin
tisane way
faire un poulet aux géraniums donc du
coup logique on récupère du géranium
j'utilise aussi les autres aromates que
dans notre jardin pour faire d'autres
réparations oui
mais j'aime pas
ça c'est trop belle et romarin tu fais
quoi base de ces trois mêmes donc
[Musique]
on va préparer les épices way to tomates
là on a du romarin je crois qui dit que
tu fais la cuisine chez toi mais une
fois pas
deux
[Musique]
alors pour un cas un ris comme jules
omnium les épices qu'il nous faut c'est
l'oignon l'ail c'est les épices
en attendant un car oui voilà oui une
traditionnelle jauzion lie tomates un
petit morceau de gingembre ça se passe
comment tu vois ta table ce qu'il faut
faut réserver on peut en manger tous les
jours à l'inter il faut réserver parce
que ben moi quand j'ai pas de clients je
vais aider patrick
séduit
[Musique]
je te couper en petits morceaux je te
prends la balle ça va non je voulais te
demander de le couper façon créole à
dans la main directement dans la main
mais dans ce sens là me couper ça sur
une planche non je n'y arrive pas
[Musique]
guillaume carrière dorée en attendant le
poulet mais tu as la vache oui ça te
complais
et du coup ça c'est quoi comme tout
laisser un poulet pays à tous les
fermiers sa ses impôts les fermiers
nourris au maïs ça se voit la taille des
cuisses bien le truc c'est pas un poulet
bicyclette ça se voit tout de suite ils
apprendront ce recul un petit peu parce
qu'il ya une bulle quand même ajouter
que
voilà on peut pas roussir les lentilles
maintenant les deux feux sont son couple
à deux mètres a rendu à temps non non je
n'aime ça ben oui il est là en titre
c'est pas qu'il faut pas les faire cuire
avoir un moment c'est joli non non non
d'accord jeu dangereux non roussy le
lentilles on met de l'eau on laisse
cuire donc pu monter à cilaos prendre
mes lentilles on l'a fait m un peu de
route
avec fabrice salle agriculteurs qui fait
du bon produit exactement d après ce qu
on reconnaît une bonne bonne menti va
pas la différence si je fais la salle à
manger sont pas homogènes mais qu'est ce
qu'ils m'ont voilà mon frappe tout de
suite
elles sont petites
fermes démentis un coq au géranium
et avec un petit rumba et après
assez folle le caisson légère la
quantité normale
[Musique]
d'abord comment quatre bornes
et l'eau du lac jamais dans les
[Musique]
salles ancien jouer
c'est bon c'est parti pour une bonne
heure de cuisson
10 ans de bonheur comme ça
[Musique]
j'avais annoncé une bonne heure de
cuisson on a dû finalement attendre 2h
faut enfin un brin l'opportunité de
goûter au fameux carry coque géraniums
de brigitte
[Musique]
en lançant foire passer à table
comme cadeau pour nous
[Musique]
voilà des tic
après cette découverte culinaire
délicieuse quel était ce cas et coques
géraniums on se trouve juste à côté de
la chapelle où vous allez voir qu'à une
histoire assez particulière et je vais
essayer d'en apprendre un peu plus sur
l'histoire aussi j'imagine particulière
de mon hôte
c'est magnifique c'est reposant alors
c'est la chapelle de madame desbassyns
elle est belle ouais se trouve pas ses
opposants c'est
[Musique]
moi
deux atouts touristiques et historiques
de poids juste à côté de chez toi le
premier c'est le musée de villèle qui
est juste de l'autre côté de la route a
à peine 500 m d'ici et cette fameuse
chapelle où étaient enterrés dans des
bassins et le reste de sa famille ça
fait combattants étaient installés ici
sur ce terrain alors on est agriculteur
là ça fait 17 ans qu'on est agriculteur
et on a repris l'exploitation
du père de patrick donc au début en fait
c'était un terrain vous pensé de la can
voilà ce n'est pas l'acte i minuit place
à la cale s'acquiert vraiment un esprit
une espèce de quiétude chez toi quoi
l'esprit familial nous envoyons semble
cadre idéal c'est agréable de pouvoir
travailler en famille comme celui moi
j'ai la chance de partager le travail de
patrick qui est dur sur l'exploitation
moi je le fais faut être très polyvalent
mais voilà et de la même manière lui
aussi le fait d'être valable aussi à la
cuisine il quand on a des clients il
descend et il vient m'aider après il ya
notre fille elodie elle est avec nous
donc elle donne un super coup de main à
la table elle l aime bien aussi donc et
après on a un petit fils qui s'appelle
jalil et liu fameux potager voilà qui à
son fameux partagé oui et luidia lille
il adore la cuisine alors je sais pas
s'il va suivre papy ou mamie ça
participe à l'ambiance en plus quoi
voilà
familias à participer dans l'ambulance
et c'est ça qui fait qu'on se sent bien
en fait quand on débarque chez toi
j'aime bien cet échange entre les gens
j'aime bien les recevoir et le montrer
ce que moi je fais simplement
avec wii avec amour et leur raconter
notre histoire je te remercie pour cette
journée
avec plaisir je vous ai reçu l'équipe
allait
prochainement sur wii
ban
[Musique]
et donc à côté de la chapelle pointue
que va se terminer cet épisode une
journée riche en découvertes et en bonne
humeur alors c'est comment vous voulez
profiter d'un joli petit bout de réunion
et d'une ambiance familiale je vous
donne l'adresse et la table paysanne
hicham en ce qui nous concerne on se
retrouve très vite sur les routes de la
réunion a plus
[Musique]